the Joe Rogan experience I feel like you
and I should do a dance competition and
Schobert and Tom but time Bert are both
athletic dudes they're actually both
athletic guys here's my prediction yeah
Tom can dance is asking yeah and legit
dance but uh but can you ever see him
swing a golf club he's an athletic dude
yeah he's a big dude too big guys um
here's my prediction yeah they keep
ramping it up really I don't think we're
done I think I think you got about to
see some epic [ __ ] really I think
they're gonna keep ramping it up oh yeah
I feel like I want in I mean I know that
I I know I'm being derivative and I'm
copying but I wanna I wanna [ __ ] get
you why don't you have your own I think
they both already have scripts written
for their retorts and I don't know who's
gonna go first well it's gotta be birds
birds got to be next cuz Tom just
murdered him you can't you can't double
down like this [ __ ] was ruthless
I mean come on man this [ __ ] was
ruthless and what happened do you spill
over yourself [ __ ] this is this video
you've seen this video right come on oh
it's the best bro it's amazing but
here's this amazing lair it's actually
good I know like this part like watch
this I mean come on look at him moving
around
dude he danced great I know and that's
why he was offended by Bert's
he's like this dudes pretending knows
how to dance just cuz it takes his pants
off I'll show you
you got more mad when people gave him
credit for it too they're like oh look a
bird dancing he did get mad yeah I
didn't understand that I was a little
confused I felt like he was laying back
like if we were gonna do a hip hop dance
contest you know I mean like he's the
guy at the bar that pretends you can't
play pool I mean I played a couple of
times oh by the way selling those
machine shirts machine you go buy those
at your mom's house calm I'm gonna
bother us I said I said that I say to
Rogen I put them on right this idea was
before they were doing the dance thing I
remember I said to I go I had sob Eddie
you and me and I said let's do a [ __ ]
dance-off and then and then yeah and
then Brogan comes back with a if we do a
dance-off you're gonna want to win and I
don't know if I have the time to
dedicate
that [ __ ] I was like.he you got serious
right away you get competitive I'm a
[ __ ] yeah I knew what you would do
whatever you had to do to win
I have kept my most ridiculous [ __ ]
tendencies at bay yes for most of my
adult life but when we did sober October
last year and I was making the fire
alarm go off from my sweat like I was
telling them I'm like you're gonna die
I'm like if you're gonna show you do
what I'm willing to do you're gonna die
you don't understand I work out 8-10
hours a day you'll kill yourself we're
gonna die
[Applause]